the Democrats have had it they've had it
okay
the midterms are tomorrow and you were
supposed to vote for the Democrats
but all the polls are showing that
you're going to vote for the Republicans
even after Joe Biden called the
Republicans fascists even after Biden
said that Republicans are a threat to
our sacred democracy you just wouldn't
listen you just you wouldn't listen you
still said that you were going to vote
for the Republicans so now
No More Mr Nice liberal establishment
according to white house chief of staff
Ron Clane you are getting one final
warning
the president decided a few days ago
that it was important to issue one final
warning on this issue to make very clear
to leave no doubt that we have people
out there still peddling the big lie
people uh now raising the issue of
election Denial in this election
one final warning
one final warning you better you listen
here are you people I'll say it one last
time it's like a father driving in a in
a station wagon with his kids in the
back you've got one last warning don't
you dare think about voting for
Republicans who does this guy think he
is one final warning and then what if we
don't do what they say or the libs going
to sick federal agents on us are they
going to censor us are they going to
threaten our businesses and our families
and our constitutional rights they're
already doing all of those things and
now they're just being more upfront
about it all that piffle about the rule
of law and our sacred democracy that
whole charade is giving way to more
naked threats and power plays
because the people don't like the powers
that be so if our liberal ruling class
wants to keep its grip on power it's
going to have to do so against the
clearly stated wishes of the people I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from Finn binach am I
pronouncing that correctly probably not
who says I don't know why they wouldn't
cheat this time since last time they did
and everyone saw it and they still
completely got away with it in what
world would they not do it again the
world in which they would not do it
again is if they can't if they don't
have the political power or the
opportunity to do it it is safe in
politics to count on if a political
campaign
and especially a left-wing political
campaign they do do this more than the
Republicans do sometimes the Republicans
do it too sometimes but the Democrats
are just much better at doing it but if
they have the opportunity to cheat
they're probably going to do it which is
why the way that we uphold the Integrity
of our electoral system is not by
hoping not only by hoping it's not by
you know crossing our fingers and saying
oh I hope it's okay this time it's by
putting procedures in place that make it
much harder to cheat and what they did
in 2020 was using the excuse of covet
they just got rid of all of those
procedures since 2020 some of them have
gone back into place the Republicans
where they have control have tightened
up on the election rules a little bit
but in some places they haven't done it
very much one I'm kind of worried about
Pennsylvania Democrats Run Pennsylvania
the state supreme court tighten things
up a little tiny bit but I could see
still see a world where if if fetterman
is within Striking Distance of Oz all of
a sudden ballots show up in the middle
of the night in Philadelphia so we'll
see what happens the only way though
that we can reliably count on the
Democrats not cheating and rigging the
elections is if they don't have the
political power to do it okay we've got
to protect ourselves you got to protect
your home that's why you got to check
out ring it is a wonderful time of year
one of my absolute favorite times of
year the fall when there were so many
wonderful things to enjoy and not just
pumpkin spice lattes the kids are back
in school the chaos of Summer travel has
come to an end and you can get back into
the swing of things
but for many of us Autumn can also be a
busy time of year with work school
sports clubs Etc you may find yourself
away from home more often than not that
is why I have teamed up with ring with
ring security products you can rest easy
knowing that your home and your family
are safe when you're not there the ring
doorbell notifies you when guests or
packages arrive Rings indoor cameras let
you keep an eye on kids and pets while
you're away ring alarm will alert you of
any motion detection while the house is
empty plus if you add smart lighting
around your home you can turn the lights
on or off while you're away which is
very very handy go to ring.com
collections slash offers two slashes
right now to find out how you can live a
little less stressed this season with a
ring product that is right for you that
is ring.com
collections slash offers
the Democrats themselves are predicting
a bad night on Tuesday tomorrow night
they're predicting a bad night which is
why the excuses are starting already
including excuses from the uh Pretender
governor of Georgia the president of the
Galactic Federation of the Universe I
speak of course of Stacey Abrams who is
way down in the polls she's getting
absolutely destroyed by Brian Kemp and
so she was asked on MSNBC do you think
you can still win and she said well yeah
of course if the Republicans don't
suppress the vote
we want to remind folks that election
day is still on Tuesday we've seen
outside turnout in the state of Georgia
among black voters but we need to
remember early voting was the beginning
not the not the end but we know that
people turned out early because they
understand that Brian Kemp and Brad
raffenberger put barriers in place that
they're going to be denied access to
food and water in Lines within years
past we've stretched up to four eight
hours they know that there have been
more difficulties put in place for
absentee ballots that white supremacist
groups and hard right-wing groups have
been challenging people's right to vote
up to 75
000 people have had their right to vote
challenge because of the law passed by
Brian Kemp and he did so because he was
frustrated by the results he gets
lionized for not committing treason but
we keep ignoring the fact that yes you
can deny the outcome of an election
which is what so many have done but it
is even more efficient to block access
to that election and that's been Brian
Kim's modus operandi
so obviously it's all nonsense but even
just take the individual claims that
she's making she's saying Brian Kemp is
stealing the election by not providing
people food and water while they wait to
vote do you think do you think the The
Ballot Box is a Michelin rated
restaurant since when do we get food and
water at the at the polls I don't
remember that I voted in every election
I could vote in in my life I've never
gotten uh yes I'll have the steak tartar
please I'll start with the state tartar
then I would like to move on to a nice I
don't know maybe an Ahi Tuna could I get
thank you so much yeah so just bring it
back to me in line while I maybe a glass
of uh Dom Perignon would be good too no
what are you talking about
they're rigging the vote because they're
not serving you a meal what on Earth are
you talking about lady well they're
rigging the vote because
thousands and thou tens of thousands of
Georgians have not been able to vote yet
hey lady it's not election day
what do you mean what do you mean they
haven't been allowed to vote yet I know
that Democrats have rigged the election
system to extend election day to
election months because one it allows
them to push off debates so they don't
have to stand by their record if people
are voting before debates take place
then debates don't really matter but two
when you expand the window for voting
you open up the opportunity for fraud
because there are going to be fewer poll
Watchers there's going to be a lot less
oversight
is going to be a lot more opportunity
for shenanigans
so she's saying long before election day
well some people haven't had their right
to first of all people should not be
voting before election day period
rare circumstances maybe you can have an
absentee ballot if you're overseas
serving in the military or something
like that if you're truly disabled you
can't get out of your house okay fine
but no we shouldn't have 75 000 people
voting before election day to begin with
now what what we're going to hear from
the left is
well the the Republicans deny elections
sometimes too first of all we do it much
less than the Democrats do but second of
all we didn't just make it a federal
issue for three years to talk about the
how if you question the results of any
election you're a threat to our sacred
democracy and you're a fascist and a
terrorist that's what the Democrats have
done and yet the Democrats now are
preemptively denying the election so
it's not the same when the Republicans
do it and when the Democrats do it the
other reason that it's not the same when
Republicans raise questions about
elections compared to Democrats is that
the Democrats have pretty much all of
the power in the country
even if the Republicans win a house of
Congress even if the Republicans have
the Supreme Court or whatever the
Democrats the Liberals have all of the
power in the country and the Liberals
are the ones
who have changed all the election laws
in recent years
so no it's not the same the when when
Republicans point out that there's some
rigging going on because ballots are
showing up in the middle of the night in
Philadelphia and they stopped counting
the vote and there was a water main
break in Georgia and that's why they had
to stop counting the vote when things
were looking bad for Joe Biden
okay when we point that out that's not
the same as saying well no that the
Republicans are rigging all the of the
elections how I don't know because
they're not serving as foie gras while
we wait to vote give me a break okay
it's not the same thing and so therefore
when the Democrats start talking about
rigging you know that it's much more
likely to be BS because the Republicans
just don't have nearly as much power in
the country the other way they're
denying it too this is this is my
favorite one this is my favorite New
York Times piece that I've seen in years
I think
so this was published November 6th just
yesterday two days before the election
Russia Russia reactivates its trolls and
Bots ahead of Tuesday's midterms
researchers have identified a series of
Russian information operations to
influence American elections and perhaps
even erodes support for Ukraine they
love Ukraine we'll get to Ukraine later
there the Russians are behind it there
it is there it is when the New York
Times was four years old and the New
York Times mommy came downstairs and
caught the New York Times with its hand
in the cookie jar do you know what the
New York Times said I guarantee you what
the New York Times said was no Mom
Russia took the cookies out of the it
was Russia
and then when the New York Times was
about 11 years old sixth grade
and uh hadn't done its homework you know
the teacher said New York Times why
didn't you do your homework and you know
what the New York Times said they said
no no Mrs McGillicuddy Russia
work it was Russia and now for every
election into the future
hey Democrats hey New York Times why why
do you guys keep losing why do the
people keep rejecting me the Bulls no it
was it was the it was the Russia
okay okay it's the Russia you got it
that's right when when the moment you
hear Russia from the the Libs from
anyone in the liberal establishment you
know things are not looking good for
them from the perspective of democracy
from the perspective of the will of the
people so Republicans are looking great
right now okay
I'm concerned about Pennsylvania
I I think herschel's looking good in
Georgia the polls just keep moving more
and more in his Direction so I'm
somewhat concerned about Blake Masters
in Arizona uh Blake is still a little
bit behind though Kerry lake is doing so
well the governor candidate that I think
Blake Masters the Senate candidate might
be able to be pulled across the Finish
Line he's a great candidate I really
like him I'm feeling good about JD Vance
I'm feeling good I'm just feeling good
about the elections generally so of
course
when Republicans are looking really
really good we have to start infighting
don't we when Republicans are looking
the strongest that we have looked maybe
in my lifetime certainly since 2010
certainly since 1994 then of course the
Republicans need to start sniping at
each other
in the meantime you are already seeing
something that's going to start on
Wednesday if you can think past
tomorrow's election looking to Wednesday
Wednesday marks not the beginning of the
new Republican Congress or whatever
Wednesday marks the beginning of the
2024 Republican presidential primary
Donald Trump has already lobbed a shot
across the bow at Ron DeSantis who is
his main rival right now for the
Republican nomination
Donald Trump has given Ron DeSantis one
of his famed opponent
nicknames before I tell you that
nickname though I gotta tell you how to
look really really good that's an
important part of politics is looking
good when you want to look good you got
to check out mizen and Maine right now
go to mizzen and maine.com use promo
code Knowles missing in Maine are the
inventors of the performance fabric
dress shirt is there anything worse is
there anything worse than being in some
uncomfortable Oxford shirt let's say
you're like me or maybe of Sicilian
extraction you're a little you're known
to perspire okay well missing and Main
figured it out gives you the performance
of an athletic shirt with a really neat
clean smart excellent style kind of look
they're just they're just phenomenal
they made the most lightweight
breathable moisture wicking dress shirts
that you can buy they're high
performance dress shirts are warm in
Winter and cool in summer think of their
clothing as a secret weapon for any
occasion I am confident if you give Miss
it and man a try you will never go back
to Conventional men's clothing again
mizzen and Maine's dress shirts are the
best they're are just absolute top of
their class plus they've got so many
other wonderful products I love the
polos in particular I love the utility I
love the style if you want the best
dress shirts money can buy check out
missing in Maine right now that is
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code nulls you'll receive 35 off any
regular priced order of 125 or more
that's 35 off when you go to m i z z e n
a n d m a i n.com use promo code Knowles
just days before very important midterm
elections Donald Trump is already
starting
the 2024 process we finally have a
nickname
for Ron DeSantis
Trump at 71 Rhonda sanctimonious at 10
Mike Pence at seven oh Mike's doing
better than I thought here we go
president Trump was at a rally and he
decides to take a shot at Ron DeSantis
it's really really interesting because
and no I haven't seen anyone else talk
about this
this is the first time that I've seen
Donald Trump pick a fight
Donald Trump fights constantly done
going back to the Rosie O'Donnell Feud
Donald Trump just will tear people apart
it's one of the reasons why I think a
lot of Republicans including Ron
DeSantis might not run in 2024 is they
don't want to just go into that meat
grinder of a trump uh campaign operation
but Trump usually responds Rosie
O'Donnell started the fight with Donald
Trump the 2016 candidates he would wait
for them to attack him and then he would
just go nuclear as far as I can tell Ron
DeSantis has not attacked Trump yet
Rhonda Santos is meeting with donors
Rhonda Sanders is clearly getting ready
to run for president 2024 but I haven't
seen him publicly attack Trump so the
fact that Donald Trump is launching this
light-hearted but still pointed attack
on Ron DeSantis this early shows clearly
Trump is a little bit concerned about
Ron DeSantis the other thing that's
interesting is you heard the crowd they
didn't erupt in Applause it wasn't like
a little Marco low energy Jeb lion Ted
it wasn't there you'd see the audience
would go crazy with that you didn't see
that with Ron de sanctimonious
for two reasons one it's not Trump's
best work there is definitely a better
nickname that he can give to Ron
DeSantis than Rhonda sanctimonious
sanctimonious is just too fancy a word I
think and the whole nickname is seven
syllables I feel that's a little bit too
long you know he Trump could have called
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas that was
that was the nickname that we were all
joking about because foe because she's
fake and then kahontas because she
pretends to be an Indian
but Trump didn't do that because Trump
rightly understood that Pocahontas is a
little too fancy it requires a little
too much thought Pocahontas everyone
gets that's funny Pocahontas everyone
knows the Disney cartoon everyone
learned about it in school
Des sanctimonious it's I to me it's a
little too clever by half now Trump has
played with nicknames before and gone
with different ones he started out with
low no stamina Hillary do you remember
that and then finally settle down
crooked Hillary was way way better so
he's got to work on it I think with uh
DeSantis I would be surprised if to
sanctimonious lasts
now all of that said
everyone seems to have picked a horse in
this fight already
and everyone seems to have forgotten
that there are other candidates who
could pop up it's very very early in
2024. for for this cycle we're talking
two years out now
but everyone seems to be on a team I
think I might be the only conservative
pundit in America who isn't just
frothing at the mouth ready to throw
Trump overboard in in support of Ron
DeSantis or or vice versa I think I'm
the only one who's saying hey guys let's
cool it DeSantis has done a great job
he's the best governor in the country
right now maybe the best governor in my
lifetime he's great
also Trump is the greatest president in
my lifetime and Trump got Roe v Wade
overruled and yes he had some help from
Mitch McConnell doing it and obviously
the judges but you know the buck stops
at the president he did great work and I
I I love Trump okay and also there are
other candidates and who knows what's
going to happen in 2024.
but DeSantis has a problem here and I
think that I think that gives me a
little credibility to to analyze the
situation that is already beginning
again I'm not I'm not pitting candidates
against each other I'm not the one like
the Democrats who want who was calling
for this fight between Trump and
DeSantis
Trump launched the fight it has already
happened I am simply observing that fact
and I'm noticing that there's a there's
a trick right now for DeSantis it could
be a great Advantage for him but it is a
challenge nevertheless which is that Ron
DeSantis his strength is that he is
considered
Trump 2.0 Trump without the baggage all
the good fight of trump but with more
political discipline and with a probably
a more fully fleshed out at least from
an intellectual or philosophical level
political point of view and so he's just
he's just Trump without the Twitter
fights he's just whatever right that's
that's the argument he's the bigger
better faster version of trump younger
right okay less
disapproval points okay
but
Trump is running or he at least is
positioning himself to run so desantis's
Lane is as the anti-trump candidate
so a lot of desantis's support is coming
from people who always hated Trump
who hated Trump in 2016 who maybe came
around to him a little bit who maybe
voted for him in 2020 but they hate
Trump and so they're looking for any
excuse to ditch Trump and so DeSantis is
the vessel for their support and the
fact that those people support DeSantis
through no fault of desantis's own
that's just his role in the race because
of that the fact that people who are a
little bit squishier a little bit more
Centrist are supporting DeSantis make
some people who are really really
gung-ho about Trump skeptical of
DeSantis himself because he's got that
kind of support around him so this is a
really fine issue that DeSantis is going
to have to figure out if he can pull it
off
if he can somehow manage to be
Trump 2.0 the bigger faster funnier
Donald Trump which again is very very
difficult to do if not impossible but if
he can do that while still keeping the
anti-trump support then yeah he's the
greatest candidate ever he's United the
party it's guaranteed but if you think
that that's just going to happen if you
think that Donald Trump is just going to
let that happen
I've got a bridge in Brooklyn to sell
you
okay that I I just don't see it and so
then you then in in the world where
Trump is just going completely hard he's
actually running he's on a tear he's
ripping candidates apart
then you're seeing Ron DeSantis who is
right now the main rival being pulled
but in two opposite directions
and he's going to figure out have to
figure out how to play that game again
these are conversations that can happen
on Wednesday but we have to acknowledge
Trump has already launched the fight and
people are pulling their hair out
because they say why are you launching
this fight right now we're supposed to
have Republican Unity I don't think it's
going to affect the midterms
I think Ron DeSantis is going to walk
away with his race that's not a problem
and then in terms of all the other races
in the country Trump and DeSantis are
pretty much on the same team
so I don't think it affects the midterms
really at all I think Republicans are
fired up Republicans obviously need to
go out and actually vote
it's not enough to just
feel excited it's not enough to just
feel good and support a candidate in
your head you actually have to go vote
if you don't then the libs could could
take it
now another issue for DeSantis
because in two days we're going to be
talking about 2024. that's just the way
in well they're probably still going to
be counting the votes in Philadelphia
but the rest of us are going to be
moving on to the 2024 race certainly the
political class they're going to start
running
one issue for DeSantis is that
he's very strong on policy he's very
strong in person his speeches are very
strong he's he's he checks pretty much
all of the boxes
his ads are not
oddly enough his
his media
is a little weak I think compared to his
record he just released an ad uh this is
kind of his last Salvo in before the
midterm elections and it was this ad
that was released from his wife's
Twitter account about how DeSantis is a
fighter
and on the eighth day
God looked down on his planned paradise
and said I need a protector
so God made a fighter
God said I need somebody willing to get
up before Dawn kiss his family goodbye
travel thousands of miles for no other
reason than to Serve the People
to save their jobs their livelihoods
their Liberty their happiness
so God made a fighter
God said I need someone to be strong
Advocate truth in the midst of Hysteria
someone who challenges conventional
wisdom and isn't afraid to defend what
he knows that's fine that's fine so get
it get it it's like the ad God made a
farmer but it's God made a fighter with
DeSantis oh goodness gracious
that is weak sauce guys the production
value is is not great and it's just a
political nerd ad it's an ad for
political nerds who remember a different
ad it's a play it's it's just not
and it doesn't really highlight DeSantis
accomplishments it just says he's a
fighter just like every other politician
ever said It reminds me there was
another terrible ad that DeSantis put
out about how he's he's basically Tom
Cruise and Top Gun
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your Governor speaking today's
training Evolution dog fighting taking
on the corporate media The Rules of
Engagement are as follows number one
don't fire unless fired upon but when
they fire you fire back with
overwhelming force does it say that in
the bill I'm asking you to tell me
what's in the bill number two never ever
back down from a fight if I could
complete the question though so you're
going to give a speech or ask a question
number three don't accept their
narrative wrong it's a fake narrative I
just disabused you of the narrative and
you don't care about the facts it's why
people don't trust people like you
because you peddle false narratives
alright ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
uh oh I don't know who made this ad I
feel bad you know I don't want to attack
these poor GOP Consultants but this is a
bad ad this is DeSantis
I love DeSantis I love the guy he's been
a great governor of Florida and he is
the only politician I know of whose ads
make him look way Lamer than he actually
is
but this is weak sauce top gov you get
out there in the Mike Dukakis helmet
come on man and so I I mention all of
this now because the 2024 race has
started Donald Trump is attacking Ron
DeSantis if DeSantis is running for
president as he seems likely to do then
if he wants to pose a credible threat to
Donald Trump
he needs to he needs to up the Dazzle a
little bit okay he's got to up the show
business a little bit he will be going
up against one of the greatest showman
in American history one of the funniest
most absolutely captivating celebrities
certainly in modern American history and
he he he's got a lot of openings where I
think he could attack Trump and and pry
pry some voters away from Trump but I
don't I don't that this isn't going to
do it okay and people really have to
look ahead there will be no time to
waste as the Republicans if the
Republicans have a good night tomorrow
night and I I'm
pretty confident that we will
and we win the state houses and we win
the house and maybe we win the Senate
maybe when the Senate by a fair margin
and maybe things are ready to go then
we've got to hit the ground running okay
and we've got to get our priorities in
order we've got to sort things out we
don't want a bloody primary to go on way
into 2024 we got to figure things out
get the party in line okay and then move
move move baby this will be a window of
opportunity for Republicans to get some
serious wins but not if we dilly dally
and keep up the circular firing squad
even with the infighting Democrat among
the Republicans the Democrats are just
looking absolutely terrible right now
one of their last shots in the midterm
election
was was to try to exploit the incident
at the Pelosi home as evidence that the
Republicans are terrorists and Nazis and
fascists and it's a threat to democracy
and so you remember there was this
incident that took place at the Pelosi
home Nancy Pelosi wasn't there her
husband was there there was a strange
man who seemed to be a kind of
nudist Berkeley hemp jewelry maker who
with BLM signs and pride Flags in his
window who nevertheless was called a
right-wing person and he was yelling
where's Nancy and there was a hammer and
Joe Biden the president of the United
States gave a whole speech about this
insinuating that this attack is just
evidence that the Republicans are a
threat to democracy this was their their
real final pitch
in the election but the details never
quite added up
you're telling me there was no security
at the Pelosi house this guy just got in
seems unlikely possible but unlikely and
then you tell there's they don't have
security cameras so we can't see this
and then the the dispatch when the 911
call was made the dispatch said that
Paul Pelosi said that he knew the guy
and his name was David and he was a
friend of his but he didn't know the guy
but he knew the stuff about him and the
whole thing
it was just kind of weird wasn't it well
it just got weirder because there's an
NBC news report
that was up
a long TV report about the new details
that have emerged in the investigation
take a listen
source is familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residence now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they've
been called to the home of the speaker
of the house after a knock and announce
the front door was opened by Mr Pelosi
the 82 year old did not immediately
declare an emergency or tried to leave
his home but instead began walking
several feet back into the foyer toward
the assailant and away from police it's
unclear if the 82 year old was already
injured or what his mental state was say
sources according to court documents
when the officer asked what was going on
defendant smiled and said everything's
good but instantaneously a struggle
ensued as police clearly saw David depap
strike Paul Pelosi in the head with a
hammer after tackling the suspect
officers rushed to Mr Pelosi who was
lying in a pool of wide
what
so the police get the call
and they say they don't know it's the
Pelosi's but they get the call they know
it's an important person
and then there was this question who
opened the door
the police didn't bust in so someone
opened the door who is the person to
open the door Paul Pelosi himself opened
the door
but he didn't run out saying oh my gosh
there's this guy he's attacking me help
me officer help me he didn't he didn't
even say this is an emergency come on
he opens the door
greets the police officers and then
walks back
to this Berkeley nudist guy the attacker
and then they're all kind of chatting
and then the attacker attacks him in
front of the police
so he hadn't the attacker hadn't
attacked Paul Pelosi before the police
got there
that's kind of weird and the whole
the whole thing is just raises way more
questions than it provides answers and
NBC News went on even further about some
of these questions
investigators have previously said
Pelosi did not know de Pap when the 42
year old broke into his home why Pelosi
didn't try to flee or tell responding
officers he was in distress is unclear
so even NBC News is there this was not
just some one-off reporter giving a
little bit of commentary on the air this
was a full news report where they even
raised the questions explicitly that are
implied by the report and then the
report's gone
it's gone you can't you can't find that
video on NBC right now they took it down
yeah well luckily we were able to get a
clip of it so it'll be on this show
until they try to take that down
it's weird that's weird isn't it of
course they deleted the report the
police have said they won't release the
body camera footage the Pelosi's are not
going to release the home security
footage
so we're left with okay I'm glad Paul
Pelosi is okay
all right at the very least
whatever occurred in the Pelosi home in
the middle of the night
it is not going to affect the midterm
elections it just hasn't had the effect
that clearly Joe Biden wanted it to have
when he gave a whole speech about it
pretty dodgy stuff pretty done a lot of
dodgy journalism about it there was a
good NBC news report but then it's dodgy
that they took it down speaking of dodgy
journalism would you believe that your
beloved host me me whom everybody loves
so
was just recently attacked by the
Southern Poverty Law Center
the splc is
a leftist attack group their whole job
is to get us fired and it's like Media
Matters but they've been around a little
bit longer and they're a little bit more
aggressive actually even than Media
Matters and they have something called
hate watch
and hate watch just did a piece that was
on me it was on other conservatives too
I wasn't even the main object of their
ire but they did go after me pretty hard
in here and I knew they were going to do
that because I got an email from this
guy who wrote it Michael Edison Hayden
months ago said Michael we're doing a
piece it's not really about you but I
want to clarify comments that you've
made on the air and uh you know what do
you think about trans women you don't
think trans women should have the rights
to
I don't know do whatever swim on the
girls team or go to the bathroom or
whatever so I get this email I know it's
a hit piece I know this guy's a radical
leftist and I know it's absurd and I
know that they have a something called
hate watch and they're going to portray
me as the worst person in the world but
I I say I'm going to respond to this guy
and I I responded with a
I felt a thoughtful polite
uh email immediately within 24 hours and
I said uh dear Michael Edison Hayden
um you you keep using this term trans
women I'm I'm afraid I'm not familiar
with that ontological category if by
trans women you mean confused men who
believe that they're women and you're
asking me if I think that they ought to
have their genitals lopped off I think
that sort of thing ought to be
discouraged I think it's a violation of
the Hippocratic Oath uh the splc wanted
me to clarify do I think that
genital you know mutilation of these
confused men who think that they're
women should that be only banned in the
culture or should that be banned by the
power of the law and the power of the
state and I said even there I said you
know
I'm even confused by that distinction
because in America we have
self-government so the idea at least in
theory is that we make our own laws and
we set the standards that we want to
live under within certain limits uh
articulated in the Constitution and so
there's not a whole bit of a difference
really between what what the people want
to do in their own society and the state
because America's supposed to have
self-government and then I even had a
little French at the end and I said to
borrow a line and adapt it from Louis
XIV in America you know we are we are
the state in America so I thought I said
if you have any questions please you
know write to me all kind regards all
the best Michael
so then he runs this piece he says
a Knowles expressed hateful views of the
lgbtq plus Community Knowles is a pundit
for the daily wire and he used his
appearance on a Newsweek show to say
that he's within his rights to tell
adult transgender women that they're not
women
and then he quotes me from the show and
initially they said Knowles did not
respond and I said this is just a lie
this is just a total lie so I pointed it
out on Twitter that I couldn't find a
guy on Twitter the guy had blocked me
this guy who reached out to me he
blocked me and
but then finally enough people tweeted
at him that he said no no I I don't have
the email I don't have it I search my
inbox I don't have it I kept using that
phrase I don't have the email I don't
have an email from Michael Knowles and I
noticed that's kind of specific diction
he didn't say I've never received an
email from Michael Knowles he said I
don't have it now so what happened it
seems like he it seemed
I I don't want to be uncharitable or
unfair but if I were a Gambling Man I
bet he did receive the email and he
deleted it so then he can say truthfully
I don't have an email but but regardless
I have the screenshots I sent him my
commentary he still clearly didn't want
to update the article he had said listen
I always quote in in its entirety the
statements given to me by the people
that I interview and so I said okay well
you have it now and he kept going on he
said I don't have the email I said well
now you have it here it is I've just
sent it to you you have the email and he
wouldn't quote it he quoted five words
of a of five words of a random sort of
analogy in my email but he wouldn't
quote pretty much anything that I said
in my email he linked to it so but he
wouldn't I thought why why why
I realized I realized why this guy
appears to have lied about receiving my
answer in the first place and why he
refuses to quote my actual answer not
just in full but really any substantial
part of it the reason why is that the
libs
the libs rely on Republicans and
conservatives being evil awful terrible
people we just have to be the the
angriest meanest cruelest most awful
people in the world and the thing is
we're not
I'm not saying there aren't some bad
guys out there but conservatives are not
actually we're generally more content
than the libs are that's why we're
conservatives we want to conserve things
you know we're generally sort of
more balanced we tend not to you know
mutilate our bodies too much and just be
angry and shrieking at the Moon all the
time so
the libs have to censor us
they can't present the real
conservatives they have to censor us
they can't allow us to State our points
of view
they the only reason that we could
defend a defend marriage the only reason
we could defend the difference between
men and women is just because we're
hateful awful bigots but they can't let
us explain why we actually think these
things because that will be very
attractive to voters
and what you've seen in recent years
increasingly in recent years is that
the conservatives get past Gatekeepers
and we find a way around and we present
what we actually believe and who we
actually are to the voters and the
voters like us and that's why you're
seeing a massive movement
across pretty much every demographic to
the conservatives and you're going to
see that reflected you've seen that
reflected in the polls already you'll
probably see that reflected at The
Ballot Box on Election night and so if
the liberal establishment wants to hold
on to its grip on power it's going to
have to become more nakedly
authoritarian it's going to it's not
going to be able to keep up the silly
claim that actually the libs who want to
kill all the babies and chop off the
genitals of the five-year-olds and erase
our borders and wage these wars of
empire in the middle of nowhere they're
not going to be able to maintain the lie
and the charade that they're doing this
because they're the voice of the people
okay that is falling apart and but the
libs don't want to give up at their grip
on Power and so they're just going to
have to become much more authoritarian
even than they already are
you know aside from the beaver blood
moon solar eclipse that's happening
tomorrow
and tomorrow's also special of course
because we're having a special event
called daily wire election night 2022.
coverage starts at 3 P.M Central and
runs until 11 p.m at 6 PM I will get
together with Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh
Andrew claven and the god king with the
lowercase G Jeremy boring and Candace
Owens to celebrate the moments as they
happen we will be giving you live
updates from the morning wire team plus
any pertinent social media meltdowns
from the likes of AOC and all of her
friends if that was not enough to get
the popcorn popping we're also going to
be joined by some very special guests
get the election news that you need to
know in real time with expert commentary
and a healthy dose of humor come
celebrate the incoming Red Wave with us
if you're not a member go to
dailywire.com Knowles and join us today
conservatives can be clear and firm
without looking angry and crazed
I think very rarely do people on the
right look angry and crazed that's how
the libs portray us but that's not
usually how we look
okay usually conservatives are pretty
fair-minded
obviously because we accept natural law
we accept objective reality we accept
the difference between men and women we
accept that babies are babies we accept
that Nations have borders we accept all
of these things that are just normal
okay it's not some far-right ideology oh
there's another far-right idiotic no
it's just called being normal okay and
the lives are not normal they're
transgressive they're subversive they
hate America they're angry all the time
they're howling at the moon so
obviously if you if you
put us on camera in a fair way
we're not going to seem so terribly
hateful you just saw this with an
interview between John Carl
and ABC News and the Republican governor
of Virginia Glenn Younkin
and John Carl he did his best
to portray the Republicans as evil and
terrible and scary and I said you want
to do all terrible awful things like
investigate the Democrats here's
junkin's answer
you know I'm hearing a lot though of
talk about investigations investigations
of Hunter Biden FBI all things Anthony
fauci Republicans talking about going
you know all in if they take control
particularly the house is that really
what what you're campaigning on to have
massive investigations and all is that
is that really even
youngin's answer was great he said well
you know we're going to do a lot of
things we're going to uh you know
Institute our kind of governing agenda
as best we can with a Democrat president
but yes yes we are going to investigate
crime and Corruption is that what are
you you're gonna run on on what on
investigating the Democrats are you yeah
you really think people want you to
investigate the Democrats who shut down
the economy for the past three years
some Republicans were part of that too
but Democrats mostly let it and shut
down all the schools and forced you to
take a dangerous experimental drug or
lose your job and you wait hold on you
and lied about everything and called
half of the country fascists and
terrorists
you think that's what the people want
yeah I do think that's what the people
want
I think the people want Justice
and I think the people have been done
over real real rough over the past few
years and I think that the people had to
have their grandparents and parents die
alone in hospitals because of stupid
cobit rules and I think the people had
their kids education severely hampered
because of the stupid covid rules and I
think that the people have lost their
jobs and their businesses and they
couldn't go to church for a long time
and a lot of it was was based on serious
corruption from people like Anthony
fauci people like the Biden family I
think that I I think people
are furious and I think that's why the
polls are so overwhelmingly for
republicans
and if Republicans
don't investigate the Democrats
who have really been audacious in recent
years and who've weaponized federal law
enforcement to spy on the opposition
party's campaigns and to undermine the
Republican duly elected Republican
Administration and to hire up 87 000 IRS
agents to go harass ordinary Americans
probably especially the ones who have
the audacity to vote Republican and to
call parents who don't want their kids
getting Trans in kindergarten terrorists
and all the rest of it I think people
hate that and they realize that if we
don't investigate that and we don't
have consequences for that then it's
just going to keep on happening
if Republicans don't launch those
investigations
I think it'd be very hard for them to
win the election next time
yeah it is urgent that we do that
what are the Democrats campaigning John
Carl seems to think the Republicans are
campaigning on some silly issue like you
know any justice for the criminals who
destroyed our country for three years
what are the Democrats campaigning on
here is here is one of the final
campaign Trail speeches from Joe Biden
do I tied an onion to my belt which was
the style at the time now to take the
fairy caused a nickel and in those days
Nichols had pictures of bumblebees on
them give me five P's for a quarter
you'd say now where were we oh yeah the
important thing was that I had an onion
on my belt which was a style at the time
sorry uh some of the clips got a little
confused here uh simple mistake to make
for the producers here is uh here is the
clip of Biden in one of his final
campaign pitches
and I know some of you are even uh
seeing whether or not you uh qualify or
whatever
you have anyway it won't go into it but
uh sorry you guys you're not supposed to
play the Grandpa Simpson clip twice did
you uh hold on I just maybe I'm just a
little confused maybe can you show me
the difference between those two clips
I don't know that I can which one is the
real Grandpa Simpson
who's really wearing the onion on his
belt which was the style at the time
the the
the speeches from Biden have become a
real symbol
for the Democrat party's midterm
campaign because it's they're just
completely aimless
they're aimless not only because Joe
Biden doesn't know where he's going or
where he is half the time they're
aimless in that they don't even know
what they're campaigning on are they
campaigning on defund the police or are
they campaigning on let's get tough on
crime
you tell me I don't know are they
campaigning on destroy the American
Energy industry or are they campaigning
on drill baby drill
I can't tell can you tell me that are
they campaigning on open up the borders
and flood the country with illegal
aliens or are they are they campaigning
on no no we're taking care of the Border
we're tougher than anybody which one is
it I can't tell and neither can the
Democrats so they're just completely
caught between a rock and a hard place
and frankly had Joe Biden been
campaigning on the onion on his belt it
would have been more coherent and
persuasive than most of what the
Democrats have talked about this cycle
do you want to talk about symbols of the
Democrat Party there was a clip
absolutely devastating from John
Federman out on the trail just a couple
of days ago campaigning is a strong wind
blew the American flags away
there he is he's talking and then they
just all all the American flags tumble
down right before this guy and he
doesn't even he's not even aware of it
I guess he didn't hear it or he wasn't
paying attempts right behind him it's
just
it was a perfect symbol okay and I'm a
big believer in Providence I'm a very
big believer in Providence I think as my
friend Father George Rottler points out
it's a wicked generation that looks for
signs and wonders but it's a stupid
generation that ignores signs and
wonders
and the world is just Rife with symbols
and that's a pretty clear one
what exactly that symbol or Omen
portends that remains to be seen
but it certainly is not a good look for
fettermen that's very true you just we
just have this sense
okay and I think it's people in the
center and people even on the center
left who are looking at the Democrats
who say you know these people
they don't seem to like us
they don't seem to like us they don't
seem to like the country they don't seem
to be very good at governing the country
the country does not seem to be doing
well under their Rule and so then the
one issue that they they focused on in
2022
where they weren't either complete
losers in their policy and or uh uh torn
between their radical base and what the
American people want which are in
contradiction with one another so the
one issue they've focused on that they
thought was going to take them across
the Finish Line was abortion
Ruby Wade gets overturned by Dobbs okay
we're gonna rally all those women we're
gonna campaign to kill the babies and
this is about how well it's going bado
O'Rourke just released this this little
insta real or Tick Tock or whatever the
hell it was uh in his final push on his
doomed campaign
it's a woman dancing says a Texas woman
who just wants rights and she's dancing
slowly and then
the creepiest dude you've ever seen in
your whole life Beto O'Rourke wearing
the one blue shirt that he owns wearing
skinny jeans like some hipster sexually
ambiguous
sophomore in college creeping up on a
girl at a party is a pro-choice governor
who's ready to fight for her and he's
just dancing slowly like it should have
been released on
on Halloween so
and I don't mean just to pick on Beto
O'Rourke though it is easy to do
Beto our work is every male feminist and
every male feminist is super duper
creepy
super creepy super weird the abortion
issue was always a loser for the
Democrats it's a even bigger loser when
it's men campaigning there's something
really creepy about hey I mean I'm gonna
fight really really hard to make sure
that if women get pregnant we can kill
the kid and I don't have to worry about
it
hey you want to watch me skateboard lady
like no get out of here you know spray
bear mace in his face or something get
out of here I don't get away from me man
stop creeping up on me well it's very
sad to think how far Beto O'Rourke has
fallen he was a an unremarkable member
of Congress then he decides that he's
going to run for Senate
so he runs for Senate in Texas and loses
and then he runs for president because
that's what happens when you lose a
senate race then you can run for
president and he had all the backing he
had all the backing of the liberal
establishment they loved this guy there
was a Vanity Fair spread
this big Vanity Fair spread of Beto and
it was on the cover he said I was built
for this I was made to be in this fight
it's all about me and I knew that was
the kiss of death
because I knew at that point Beto is
just a completely contrived thing
and this is why the libs are losing
right now and why they can't make sense
of why they're losing because they're
believing their own press releases okay
and this is some of the best advice my
mother ever gave me when I was a kid I
was a little kid and I did really well
on the test and I don't know I was uh
top of my class or something I got a
swell head and she said you know Michael
don't believe your own press releases
and the Democrats have believed they're
on press releases and they've really
convinced themselves I think a lot of
them have convinced themselves they
really are the voice of the people the
Democrat the Republicans really do pose
an existential threat they have Democrat
the Republicans really are the Nazis the
Democrats are the only four standing in
the way of the Nazis it's the people
understand this they see it and it's
just not true and people are laughing at
them and they're laughing the people are
laughing at the New York Times over
Russia Russia Russia and the people are
laughing at the Southern Poverty Law
Center over the you know Pearl clutching
at the observation that men are not
women and women are not men and we
shouldn't chop each other's genitals off
to think otherwise and we we shouldn't
trans the kids and people like borders
and people like a good economy and the
Democrats they've just they're so locked
in their own Echo chamber and they have
that Echo chamber because they have
virtually all the power in the country
the people I think still have some say
in it and if the if the people get a
little
if the people assert their rights and if
the people assert
their rights at the polls and they
express what they want for their country
you're going to have to see the
Democrats make a choice here the liberal
establishment will have to either give
up some power give up some of what it
wants to do or clamp down twice as hard
and and become more overtly
authoritarian this is what you see when
Ron clay and the white house chief of
staff comes out and he says one last
warning don't do this people one I'm
giving you one last warning that's not
just a warning about the Republic what
the Republicans will do in power it's a
warning about what the liberal
establishment will do
if the people vote for their opponents
now it is music Monday so the rest of
the show continues on we've got a a
great song I am told this was chosen by
associate producer Jacob
he's a rap mogul apparently it's a
conservative rap song I know I did I
didn't want to I know but hey he he says
it's really really great so we'll check
it out on music Monday I'll be chatting
with you over at the member block if
you're not already a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
oh
[Music]